what do you think like has been because
i feel like there's been a lot of
artists who are kind of from your era
that maybe went like a little
underappreciated maybe a little under
the radar maybe feel the same way you
feel what what would you attribute that
to i think it's a mix right like
regardless of like the fact that the
latin [ __ ] is huge now right when i
entered the space i was a brand new
artist a brand new idea like all the
latino artists in the past historically
have been like very
like more gangster more street like you
were like kind of like late blog era
yeah i missed the early i missed like
the the blog era where everybody was
popping yeah
so i think it was a mix of like the
labels not knowing what box to put me in
right and then um
kind of like catching the tail end of
the blog era and not really like
wanting to
like transition to the streaming era
like we kind of fought it a little bit
right like why am i giving records away
for free
you know and then um
you know i had like some personal [ __ ]
like some like i was with violator for a
little bit and like when chris lighty
passed it like it [ __ ] me up a little
bit right right right um [ __ ] a lot of
people up for sure exactly so rest in
peace to chris and you know just
i had to get my [ __ ] together i wasn't
ready emotionally to do a lot of the
things that i'm like feel like i'm ready
for now like one thing they don't tell
you about in music is like yeah you
could be talented you can make records
but if your mindset isn't right
you're not gonna i feel like you're just
not gonna be given those opportunities
hmm you know like or maybe you're not
ready for them exactly or you can't even
recognize that they're there to activate
them yeah it's like yeah cause like at
that time you know i had a-list artists
calling me and [ __ ] and like trying to
insert me into situations that they were
developing and i didn't even really know
at the time like how to capitalize on
those opportunities who's trying to sign
you i forget who it was there was some
there's there was some talk about you
signing with somebody we went to uh we
were talking with rose i was going to
say i thought it was mmg yeah there was
a couple other ones that weren't like
publicized i just keep it private i
remember the mmg one yeah that's the one
i think i'm thinking of how far did that
get down the line because he was trying
to sign a lot he was trying to sign you
nipsey uh [ __ ] dom kennedy yep um
i mean rose i think he was in the middle
of changing labels from like warner to
def jam it was warner yeah well it was
warner to atlantic oh okay warner to
atlantic yeah cause that was when uh mmg
originally was on warner and then there
was a big
i don't know what happened but then
everything from mmg ended up on atlantic
yeah exactly and i think we
we weren't organized on my end
you know
when i had like the spotlight at that
moment
it was accidental it wasn't deliberate
like i had done a record with like big
crit and laws and i remember shout outs
to laws from tampa big shouts what
happened to loss i think another one got
caught up laws i think the team he was
working with took the joy out of the
creator wasn't he working with justice
league i can't say names definitively so
you're saying the justice league took
the creative process out of i'm just
kidding no i mean rook i love rook and i
love the justice league they're some of
my favorite producers of all time but i
think you know when you deal with
certain people they haven't popped an
artist off let's be honest they're
[ __ ] incredible
but i mean they they also signed a homie
from tampa what was the kids name prime
prime nice kid from tampa i mean i lived
in tampa and just seemed [ __ ]
legendary they're some of my favorite
producers of all time i mean they have
like the best rick ross songs of all
time ever yeah but like outside of the
rick ross stuff i think they gave him
his sound you know they gave him his
sound a reality and i really wish that
like i really wish they i would i wish
they did more [ __ ] like maybe they are
and i'm just not hip to it you know but
i'll say this laws was fire laws is
super talented yeah and i don't know if
it was like the label side of things i
don't know where but somewhere along the
line he lost the love first because he
was hard i think he's dropping records
again now though but i think that's why
he stepped back you should reach out
there lorac let's reach out to laws
let's bring tampa find out the laws i
[ __ ] with laws heavy good dude that was
kind of yeah he was kind of like late
blogger guy too you guys are kind of the
same kind of you know yep yeah so you
did the record with laws and crit yeah
and it just like the way i came off on
the record put a lot of attention on me
that i wasn't ready for like i didn't
even have [ __ ] records done right
right so it was like we were in a
situation where i was like as you know
right you got to have [ __ ] ready to go
for sure immediately and we were just
chasing our tail yeah so
i had to step back pause build up like a
folder a hard drive hundreds of records
videos all that [ __ ] and just get ready
to execute so when uh you did you like
meet face to face with ross about the
whole [ __ ] yeah we flew out um
or i flew out to oakland one time with
him
i was in philly with him one time was
meek miller in philly i don't i don't
think so i think it was on they were on
tour with lil wayne yeah at the time
there's a
few artists on image like i love to pill
shout out to my guy pi double little
pill is super dope too he's super dope
yeah i don't know what happened man he
was so fire though well i kind of know
what happened but shout out to pill he's
a he's a great guy sometimes your demons
get the bestie that's what i'll say oh
yeah i don't know pill was a beast man
but yeah not that that i feel like you
were part of like a dope class of
rappers i just feel like sometimes man
like at the end of the day man like you
said sometimes you're not ready
sometimes
i had to be humble too i was a dick bro
99 of this [ __ ] too is luck
like people think that like
it's hard work it's person you got to be
ready to like be persevering persevered
through all kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ] and you
also got to catch a break yep and that's
the thing right i think
when you're talented i think you can
create opportunities right by being
consistent right but if you're not
consistent and those
come it [ __ ] you yeah for sure and also
like i was a cocky little prick bro yeah
you were a little cocky yeah i thought
it was cool with me but i felt that for
sure yeah i had to be humble you had
rapper syndrome yeah that happens all
with a lot of guys yep i had to be
humbled and i feel like you know some
people never got humbled and they just
accelerated you know
popped off
by the way humbled what you just did
looked like the hitler salute we're
going to point out that's not what he
did that's not what i did
he said sorry
anyway no um
uh yeah so what would you say humbled
you
life bro like having situations that i
was planning on right not paying out
yeah you know and like
i was i was with a team of talented
individuals and we weren't necessarily
always seeing eye to eye and
when things you know when when [ __ ] that
you're planning on happening doesn't
happen and it happens repeatedly you
start to realize like all right maybe
i'm the problem right you know so i had
to look internally and like really
examine my behavior my level of
preparation for certain things like you
know when you come to an interview you
got to make sure you have your bars
ready right you know it was different
then it's like
i got this yeah yeah and it's like now
i'm like you know what like
this is a spot that a lot of people
would kill to be in even the spot that
i'm in now yeah for sure so i i can't
take that for granted and i can't act
like it's owed to me i can't act like
any relationship is owed to me or any
interaction is owed to me that's great
people respect yeah most people really
need to
walk that way man yep a lot of people
don't and it's it's catching up to a lot
of people it is and then they end up
like oh [ __ ] and
by then all their [ __ ] relationships
are burnt to the ground bro